we've already been exposed to points and
lines now let's think about planes and
you can view planes as really a flat
surface that exists in three dimensions
that goes off in every direction so for
example if I have a flat surface like
this and it's not curved and it just
keeps going on and on and on in every
direction now the question is how do you
specify a plane well you might say well
let's see let's think about a little bit
could I specify a plane with one point
right over here let's call that point a
with that alone be able to specify a
plane well there's an infinite number of
planes that could go through that point
I could have a plane that goes like this
where that point a sits on that plane I
could have a plane like that or I could
have a plane like this I could have a
plane like this where point a sits on it
as well so I could have a plane like
that and I could just keep rotating
around a so one point by itself does not
seem to be sufficient to define a plane
well what about two points let's say I
had a point B right over here well
notice the way I drew this point a and B
they would define a line for example
they would define this line right over
here
so they would define they could define
this line right over here but both of
these points and in fact this entire
line exists on both of these planes that
I just drew and I could keep rotating
these planes I could have a plane that
looks like this
I could have a plane that looks like
this that both of these that both of
these points actually sit on I'm
essentially just rotating around this
line that is defined by both of these by
both of these points so two points does
not seem to be sufficient let's try
three so there's no way that I could put
well let's be careful here so I could
put a third point right over here Point
C and C sits on that line and C sits on
all of these planes so it doesn't seem
like just a random Third Point is
sufficient to define to pick out any one
of these planes but what if we make the
constraint
that the three points are not all on the
same line obviously two points can will
always define a line but what if the
three points are not collinear so
instead of picking C is a point what if
we pick what if we is there any way to
pick a point D that is not on this line
that is on that is on more than one of
these planes well no if I say well say
the point D let's say point D is right
over here so it sits on this plane right
over here one of the first ones that I
drew so Point D sits on that plane
between point D a and B there's only one
plane that all three of those points sit
on so a plane is defined by three non
collinear points so D a and B you see do
not sit on the same line a and B can sit
on the same line DNA can sit on the same
line D and B can sit on the same line
but a B and D does not sit on they are
non collinear so for example right over
here in this diagram we have a plane
this plane is labeled s but another way
that we can specify plane s is we could
say plane and we just have to find three
non collinear points on that plane so we
could call this plane
AJ b a.j b we could call it plane g jbw
plane j BW we could call it plane and I
could keep going plane a wja W J a but I
could not specify this plane uniquely by
saying so I could not say plane plane a
B W and the reason why I can't do this
is because a B W are all on the same
line and this line sits on an infinite
number of planes I could keep rotating
around the line just as we did over here
it does not specify only one plane